as we are with Anthony Ruby a network
superintendent for st. Louis schools and
the first of all welcome to our show
thank you so much for having me you've
been responsible for implementing chess
in 33 schools i believe 11 of them
during the school day why chess why do
you feel that is that important it's
it's an amazing opportunity for our kids
to experience more than the normal
curriculum it gives them a lot of the
access to skills and strategy that you
wouldn't see in a normal academic
program and I'm especially passionate
about bringing it in during the school
day so this is a for many of my students
across the 12 elementary schools that I
supervise this is a normal part of their
week 30 40 minutes an hour even of chess
as a regular academic class every day or
once a week for most students at once a
week for a few it might be everyday but
it's it's a chance to expose them and
these are students as young as three and
four years old so all the way all the
way down to our youngest pre-k students
up through eighth grade and some of my
schools we also have programs in middle
and high schools as well what are some
of the results that you're seeing those
you've implemented a program we're a lot
more active engagement in the
traditional academic classes so we see
students building more of a focus and a
stamina you see students that are
becoming more problem solvers than
reactors which is really exciting to see
you in st. Louis Public Schools and and
kids are just getting passionate about
you know hobby something that they can
learn from but also really enjoy now I
believe you were a chess player yourself
did the kids ever challenge you and you
walk into a room where you just want to
sit down and play with the kids every
once in a while so is it when I was a
teacher I coached chess and then as a
principal I had a chess team and I
played with pretty aggressively in my
role now I don't usually get to stop in
and play kids and chest but every once a
while I do get to start a quick game I
play chess at home with my kids now
which is a lot of fun absolutely what is
the relationship with the Chess Club
here how how is having a world-class
organization like this just Club
impacted what's happening in and st.
Louis Public Schools so we've been
playing chess in some of our schools for
years
years but the partnership with the st.
Louis chess club and scholastic center
has made it you know it's made our
program world-class so we now have
trained instructors that are getting the
best the best resources and the you know
the best connections to the world of
chess they're coming into our schools
rather than us piecemealing things
together and kind of making a patchwork
program so it brings a level of
professionalism and refinement to what
we had been providing so what's the next
step you're in 33 schools you're going
to be in 330 schools so we have about 75
schools across st. Louis and I hope
within the next year or two will have at
least some sort of program in every one
of those schools many of them might be
full day programs we have kids using it
as a as a regular class and in any that
that's not a possibility at least
getting a fully formed and operational
chess club after school so at least
giving every kid in st. Louis Public
Schools a chance to play chess if that's
something that they want to do the final
question is this how is the response
been the reception been from teachers
administration administrators principals
as you bring in chess into the schools
for some it's a bit of a hesitation at
first but within days sometimes weeks
definitely buy now at this point in the
year everyone's excited by it they love
it they love having kids excited they
like seeing what's possible and I think
we've really shown that in the schools
that we have established now and that's
why we're hoping to expand even more
next year fantastic well thank you so
much excellent thank you near and dear
to my heart yep Anthony Ruby doing great
were absolutely st. Louis schools the
network superintended with a grand
vision for chess and the city's children
Anthony I've got a question I can't let
you escape without asking this because
you're I was growing up in chest and I
was trying to get my school to support
chess programs or chest and school it
wasn't even a consideration that it
would be an in-school activity in class
activity is only an after school and I
had to work hard to even get that what's
changed why is it suddenly possible to
have chest inside the classroom
remind after school yeah so we are all
about ensuring equal access and one of
the things that is most important for me
as a network superintendent in st. Louis
Public Schools having an urban education
background it's all I've ever known the
most important thing is to to make sure
that kids have equal access and when we
when we have to have things after school
there's a chance that kids can't access
it because of transportation issues
because of the time of the day so by
bringing it into the school day having
it be a normal part of the curriculum it
ensures that every kid can at least get
touched by that program in some way and
if they become really excited by it they
might join the competitive team and
travel and things like that but at least
they're able to to try it and to learn
some of those foundational skills that's
why it's so important to do it during
the day well thank you sir thank you so
much thank you a great work and continue
the fantastic stuff without following
its anybody would league